en esta clínica de barcelona decenas de
mujeres europeas acuden cada día a
abortar este francés acompaña a su mujer
demasiado agotada para hablar él desea
permanecer en el anonimato
aunque concha
nos dimos cuenta de que el niño que
íbamos a dar a luz tenía una enfermedad
genética y decidimos no tenerlo pero el
plazo legal en francia había pasado no
había demasiadas soluciones tuvimos que
ir al extranjero el feto parecía un
síndrome que no está reconocido en
francia para justificar un aborto más
allá de las 12 semanas de embarazo por
ello la pareja se fue a españa donde el
plazo es de 14 semanas incluso puede
ampliarse a 22 semanas en caso de
problema médico solucionados enterarse
de que no era posible abortar legalmente
en francia- en la clínica que nos hizo
el seguimiento desde el principio es
cierto que fue muy difícil de aceptar el
doctor barambio dirige otro centro
especializado en interrupciones del
embarazo él también recibe regularmente
a mujeres francesas
según el ginecólogo el plazo legal
fijado por la ley plantea un problema en
el caso de los síndromes que se detectan
demasiado tarde pero también en los
casos en los que las mujeres no son
conscientes de su embarazo
y tienen los recursos bien conocidos y
entonces se podría encontrar que les
pasa les pasa el tiempo las mujeres muy
jóvenes que son las que más hacen la
negación y a veces no quieren creer que
estar embarazadas y después también las
mujeres mayores son las mujeres que se
quedan embarazadas cuando creen que ya
no se pueden quedar embarazadas el
problema es que no todas las francesas
tienen medios para viajar a españa una
injusticia según esta asociación sin
contar el viaje ni nada ni el
alojamiento en que quedarse entre
trescientos y dos mil euros dependiendo
del además de españa' miles de francesas
viajan cada año a otros países con
plazos más flexibles como el reino unido
o los países bajos